jack ma is one of the few entrepreneurs
in the world who have been able to
create over 1 trillion worth of value in
the marketplace last year in october of
2020 jack's companies were valued at a
total of 1.326 trillion dollars but
within just eight months his empire
shrunk to 696 billion dollars meaning
that he shed 630 billion dollars in
eight months that's the same as 78
billion dollars per month since then
things have only gotten worse as alibaba
has shed another 150 billion dollars in
the past four months putting jack's
total market cap loss at 780 billion
dollars
so what in the world happened to jack
maw
one year ago jack was killing it he was
the richest man in china he was a
massive celebrity and he was about to
conduct the world's largest public
offering with this finance company the
ant group but all of this would change
overnight on october 24th 2020 jack gave
a speech preceding the ipo of the ant
group he shared his thoughts on the
future of fintech along with a bit of
criticism of the chinese financial
system jack said quote we cannot
regulate the future with yesterday's
means there's no systemic financial
risks in china because there's no
financial system in china the risks are
a lack of systems now to most of us this
wouldn't seem like a big deal compared
to the things americans say about joe
biden and donald trump jack's remarks
are baby talk but the chinese government
would beg to differ
nowadays given the rapid financial and
technological advancements in china many
of us consider china to be a rapidly
developing country if not a developed
country i mean in terms of gdp the
general consensus is that china
overtaking the us is just a matter of
when not if so you would think that
china's political system is also quite
advanced but this is not the case
at all
you see the chinese government is run by
the ccp or the chinese communist party
and this isn't just for show either they
strongly believe in communist ideologies
and principles the reason that they
embraced a capitalistic economy is
because they realized that they couldn't
keep up with western countries without
capitalism but don't let that fool you
the ccp keeps a close eye on the free
market and they shut down anything and
everything that they consider a threat
jack's statement in october was a red
flag that the ccp had given jack way too
much freedom and they decided that it
was time to put him and all of his
billionaire friends in their place about
a week later on november 2nd jack was
invited to a closed door meeting with
chinese financial regulators at the time
this just seemed like a formality the
ant group was about to go public and the
meeting was presumably about the ipo the
next day though it would become clear
that the meeting was not so benign ant
group announced that they would be
canceling the ipo and that they would be
returning funds to investors who had
front randy ipo the wall street journal
later revealed that jack offered a
portion of the company to the ccp to
keep as long as they wanted but the ccp
declined its offer and all of this was
just the beginning after the ipo
cancellation the ccp began to crack down
on the ant group with regulation the ant
group was ordered to create a subsidiary
holding company that followed the rules
of the banking industry this way china's
massive state-owned banks could purchase
stakes in the subsidiary group the ccp
also targeted the and group's greatest
asset which was their consumer data the
ant group had gathered financial data on
billions of consumers throughout the
company's history and this was one of
their key competitive advantages the ccp
branded this data as a monopoly on
information and forced the ant group to
share this data with the rest of the
chinese financial industry while the ant
group was bending to the ccp's every
wish jack ma had disappeared he didn't
make any public appearances or speeches
he completely stopped tweeting in fact
he hasn't tweeted to this day and the
jack would miss the finals of his own
talent show where he was a judge there
is a lot of speculation that jack was
brought into custody and given a shakeup
during this time period but there's no
concrete proof thus far
moving back to the ant group the ccp
continued their demolition of the once
thriving fintech company one of the
crown jewels of the ant group was their
money market fund which was at one point
the largest in the world the ccp had
already been stifling the fund for a few
years at this point but this time they
didn't even have to do anything all of
the regulation the ccp forced onto the
ant group understandably spooked
investors of the fund and they would
leave in droves in the first quarter of
2021 the fund shrunk 18 to just under 1
trillion yuan
this adds up to almost a 50 decline from
the peak of the fund at the end of 2017.
on the bright side jack finally
resurfaced into the public's view in
early february
jack was spotted playing golf at the sun
valley golf resort and with that the ccp
decided to momentarily leave the ant
group and jack ma alone and move on to
jack's other assets in april the ccp hit
alibaba with a record 2.8 billion
anti-trust fine
apparently alibaba had eliminated and
restricted competition within the online
retailing space now i actually think
there's a bit of truth here as alibaba
is arguably a monopoly just like amazon
but alibaba's dominance hasn't really
changed over the past several years so
this is clearly just another hit on jack
alibaba put out a statement shortly
after that they would quote ensure its
compliance with the determination moving
forward the ccp took aim at alibaba's
web browser called the uc browser uc
browser was the second most popular
browser in china with over 400 million
active users only beat now by chrome in
march the ccp went ahead and removed the
app from the app store they didn't
provide any reasons as to why or give
any warning they straight up just
deleted the app to make things worse
jack's actions didn't just screw over
himself but also most chinese tech
companies the ccp was enacting very
similar punishments to all tech
billionaires in the country take diddy
for instance diddy is basically the
chinese uber and they have major players
backing them including apple tension and
uber the company was planning an ipo
during the summer and though the ccp
didn't block the ipo blocking the ipo
would have likely been the better
outcome for diddy
instead the ccp let diddy have their ipo
and right after the company went public
they announced the cyber security probe
into ditty they ordered diddy to not
accept any new customers and they
deleted the app from the app store let's
just say diddy's ipo didn't go too well
anyway moving back to jack ma on top of
the ccp tearing down his companies the
americans would decide that they wanted
to jump in on the fun as well
for years the sec has been trying to
crack down on chinese companies by
forcing regular american audits you see
almost every year one or two fraudulent
chinese companies make their way onto
the american stock market and cause
american investors to lose billions the
sec believes that imposing audits could
catch these frauds early on and save
investors from getting scammed
personally i think this is a serious
concern that does need to be addressed
but unfortunately for jag this couldn't
have taken place at a worse time at the
end of 2020 and the beginning of 2021
the sec really increased the pressure on
chinese companies they basically made an
ultimatum that they were going to d-list
chinese companies from the u.s stock
market if they didn't comply with sec
auditing the ccp of course refused to
cooperate the sec did give chinese
companies up until 2024 to comply so
there is still quite a bit of time left
and i'm not sure if things will actually
escalate to de-listing nonetheless
chinese investors didn't want to hold on
to their stocks that could potentially
lose their american investors in the
coming years and american investors
obviously didn't want to hold on to
stocks that could get delisted so
everyone just started dumping all their
positions and in the crossfire alibaba
stock got annihilated since its peak
last october alibaba stock is down over
50 percent
even after all of this the ccp still had
more in store for jack
in april the ccp launched an
investigation into aunt's relationship
with the shanghai stock exchange with
this investigation the ccp was basically
accusing the ant group of insider
dealing and corruption that's a month
the ccp attacked jack's university
called hapon university
hapon university is an extremely
prestigious and elite school in china
founded by jack ma in 2015. it's not
exactly an academic-centered university
it's more of a networking program for
up-and-coming business leaders in china
the requirements to apply to the school
include 4.5 million in revenue per year
and a minimum of 30 employees so the
school was quite a lead indeed jack was
originally a teacher so this was right
down his alley however the ccp had some
other plans
in april the ccp forced the school to
halt new enrollments they would also
force jack to step down as president of
the school and they would force the
school to drop university from its name
with the other parts of jack's life
dismantled the ccp returned to screwing
over the ant group in june china forced
the ant group to create a new company
called chongqing and consumer finance
and this new company would absorb the
most profitable parts of the ant group
the ant group was allowed to own a 50
stake in the company but they had to pay
for it the ant group literally had to
pay 625 million dollars to own half of
their own subsidiary
meanwhile a company called huarong asset
management was given five percent of the
company for free huawei actually has a
dark history of corporate corruption and
bribery
in fact their former ceo lai xiaomin was
executed for bribery and corruption in
january of this year so it's quite odd
that the ccp is forcing the ant group to
work with huarong maybe they're trying
to get the ant group involved in some
sort of scandal who knows
unfortunately that's still not the end
of the story
just three weeks ago alibaba quote
unquote donated 15.5 billion dollars or
one-third of their entire cash reserves
to president xi jinping's common
prosperity fund hopefully with this
contribution and jack will finally
regain some freedom having heard how
hard jack's companies have gotten
screwed over the past year i suspect
that you're no longer surprised to hear
that his companies have lost 780 billion
valuation within 11 months but it seems
like jack always knew that it would come
down to something like this as he said
quote i think among the richest men in
china few have good endings do you guys
think jack deserved his punishment
comment that down below
also drop a like if you think jack has
been punished more than enough and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one